bonjour eric dauphin merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france alors vous travaillez en
allemagne vous habitez en moselle
comment est ce que vous vous organisez
racontez nous quelle est votre activité
précisément j'ai donc un restaurant un
sitting bull qui se trouvent quatre
kilomètres derrière la frontière et donc
pour me m'organiser je vais voir ça tout
à l'heure puisque je vais tenter de
passer la frontière je verrai comment ça
va se passer je ne sais pas si les
frontières sont fermées où il faut
passer ce qui est comment parce que pour
le moment j'ai pas de tests disponibles
vous n'avez pas pu en faire en france
écoutez j'ai eu dimanche c'est tombé
dimanche donc pour le test et j'ai l'âme
elle de la chambre du commerce
en allemagne il y avait cent mille tests
délit de disponible et je voulais me
rendre donc lundi et les cent mille
tests sont déjà donnés donc il ya plus
de tests disponibles et on n'a pas plus
d'informations
donc aujourd'hui je vais devoir me
déguiser pour voir si quand même aller
en allemagne que trouver un autre test
dans un autre gros ou de houe voir en
france ça veut dire que l'allemagne a
prévu de fournir des tests aux
travailleurs français qui travaillent en
allemagne c'est cela et ça oui et bien
avait cent mille 2 disponible puis sont
partis en l'espace de quelques heures
enfin les poules mais on n'a pas plus
d'informations on sait pas comment ça va
continuer ça c'est côté allemand on a vu
aussi les élus français qui tape du
poing sur la table parce qu'ils disent
qu'en france il ya pas à ces tests pour
pouvoir mettre en application cette
mesure allemande vous compter sur la
clémence des autorités allemandes
je crois pas que ça sera possible donc
aujourd'hui dans la journée je vais
essayer de 2,2 de trouver un test dayan
gérer en pharmacie ou chez le médecin je
sais que hier il y avait une queue
incroyable chez le ch et le chez les
médecins donc je vais voir comment ça va
se passer au jeu de la journée mais je
ne pense pas que
je pourrais passer les frontières comme
ça donc ça veut dire si vous ne passez
pas la frontière pas de travail dans
votre restaurant aujourd'hui exactement
c'est ça c'est ça
aprilia pas qu'il n'ya pas que les
travailleurs français notation qui
verront qu'ils vont en faire les courses
en allemagne pour eux c'est pareil ils
passeront pas non plus quoi oui sauf que
vous vous travaillez donc les
restaurants sont bien ouverts en
allemagne contrairement à la france
c'est une histoire
les responsables sont fermés mais vous
travaillez quand même si on l'espère
mais c'est celle c'est le même principe
qu'en france on peut faire dieu à
emporter quoi mais les instants sur
fermé qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
vous c'est contrainte supplémentaire
dans un contexte déjà très difficile
écoutez c'est juste la tente qui est
très gênante puisqu'on a pas vraiment
d'information n'a pas de deux visuels on
sait pas quand ils se retrouvent rire de
semaine car semaine six semaines donc
c'est surtout ça ce qui est et ce qui
est très très stressant quoi est ce que
vous avez pu lire les deux des temps on
a mais est ce que vous avez pu échanger
avec vos collègues allemands vos clients
allemands qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent de
cette mesure
écoutez j'ai pas vraiment de nouvelles
de mes collègues allemands comparé au
premier
confie mange avec elle j'avais des
relations avec avec les collègues
mais là le deuxième confirmant je crois
que chacun est dans son petit coin et
puis puis attend les nouvelles quoi est
ce qu on pourrait dire que finalement
côté allemand c'est la même incertitude
que ce qui se passe en france avec des
restrictions qui sont quand même un peu
plus sévère en allemagne oui non c'est
vrai que tout le monde est vraiment dans
le flou c'est pareil qu'en france et
puis c'est vraiment de les décisions
d'un jour sur l'autre bains dimanche
il y avait la nouvelle chambre des
commerces et puis on avait juste un jour
pour trouver les propres auxerre tester
donc c'était un peu compliqué voit si on
compte les seize mille travailleurs
frontaliers plus les gens qui veulent se
ré coursan l'allemagne ça fait un peu
beaucoup pour une journée quoi donc
c'est très très très très court trop
court
merci eric dauphin d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin dans la matinale de rmc france
je le rappelle vous avez un restaurant
en allemagne et vous vivez dans le
département de la moselle